et que gérard vespière analyste
géopolitique chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous alors
tout d'abord pourquoi ce changement
soudain de la part de joe biden c'est
pas un changement soudain je pense qu'il
était effectivement d'un point de vue
matériel très difficile à de bouger
autant d'effectifs militaires sur
quelques jours ou en tout cas sur
quelques petites semaines
premièrement à deuxièmement il était
aussi difficile de faire en sorte que le
non respect par les talibans d'un
certain nombre je dirais de dispositions
en particulier à le fait qu'il est elle
toujours mené des attaques alors qu'ils
devaient réduire leur activité à
troisièmement que il était il est
absolument nécessaire
aurore le futur qu'il y ait des contacts
à entre le gouvernement officiel afghan
et les talibans
donc il est a besoin de temps donc il ya
besoin de temps pour ces pourparlers
il y a besoin de temps pour que les
troupes américaines et les troupes de
l'otan
or quittent le pays donc voila et le
délai supplémentaire rentre dans ce
cadre là alors on entendait anthony
blinken nous dire tout simplement que la
mission des états unis avaient été
accomplis réussi et donc qu'elle est
terminée tout simplement le président
afghan gagny assure lui que les forces
afghanes sont désormais pleinement
capable de défendre l'afghanistan est ce
que oui
les etats unis ont réussi leur mission
et deuxièmement est ce que les forces
afghanes peuvent défendre l'afghanistan
en toute autonomie
il est toujours difficile de faire des
parallèles aussi rapide n'est ce pas
mais à si nous fermons les yeux et nous
revoyons à la situation afghane en 2001
avec les talibans au pouvoir après la
l'élimination du commandant massoud
après la destruction des bouddhas de
bamiyan qu'il y avait plusieurs
plus de mille ans je pense que oui
ya quand même une organisation de la
société afghane avec un gouvernement
avec une évolution des mentalités on
voit maintenant un certain nombre de
femmes de jeunes filles donnent au
travail on voit des jeunes filles dans
les écoles qui est une évolution au
cours de cette génération une vingtaine
d'années et est ça je pense que ça va
marquer les esprits et la société
afghane
il y a toujours l'afghanistan des
campagnes l'afghanistan rural
mais l'afghanistan des villes si je puis
dire et bien a quand même connu une
évolution est aussi une évolution
favorable de son pouvoir d'achat de son
niveau de vie
alors les taliban tout en sons sont pas
très contents de ce changement de la
part de joe biden ce retard la russie
estimait on l'a entendu et de son côté
que ce retard risque de provoquer une
escalade washington revenons sur son
accord passé avec les talibans c'est un
risque réel que vous partagez une
escalade dans la région je pense qu'il
ya un autre paramètre qu'il faut aussi
citer c'est la présence de l'état
islamique n'est ce pas autant les
talibans europe
les discussions ont lieu avec eux autant
les discussions ont lieu aussi bien à
moscou qu'à istanbul loit en quarts 1 à
mais le problème qui peut être nouveaux
pour l'afghanistan
c'est la présence de l'état islamiste
qui se prend 6 ce qui se prend à mener
un certain nombre d'attentats contres en
particulier la minorité chiite musulmane
afghane donc ça va être dans les années
dans les mois à venir
un souci pour le pouvoir et aussi pour
les talibans d'être peu porte peut être
déporté à sur leurs extrémités sur leur
radicalisme par un autre mouvement
djihadiste les américains ont promis de
continuer de soutenir le gouvernement
afghan à distance en ce moment
décidément le distance yale en quoi ça
va à consiste
je crois que le soutien est d'abord et
économique à l'illiade donc depuis de
nombreuses années des démissions et ça
donc des organismes qui ont apporté un
des moyens conséquents dont la
distribution n'est peut-être toujours
été très tard fait n'est-ce pas la
corruption existe dans tout l'orient
amer en tout cas c'est l'âme de dans une
situation apaisée en afghanistan c'est
d'un point de vue politique à des
négociations entre les différents
groupes et factions du pays est aussi un
développement économique
il y à un certain nombre de potentiels
dans le domaine des minerais il y a une
richesse du sol afghan pas forcément que
pour l'opium
il ya des possibilités agricole donc
voilà il faut que cela puisse se mettre
en place et les etats unis auront un
rôle à jouer important qu'ils ont déjà
mis en place depuis vingt ans merci
gérard avait ce père d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur air france